[Music]
After all, when you see the cabbage for the first time from someone who
doesn't know Kyaraben, you'll be surprised that Umeka is too cute to eat.
What you put in your lunch box is
called Kyaraben. My name is Tomomi Maruo. Kyaraben and
food artists also say that you can make it with ingredients like drawing a human face
.
Michael Jackson listens to Pokemon
Doraemon or Kitty who was a girl from President Obama and goes to mold.
Also, Totoro
and most of Japan have many kindergarbens that bring lunch, so moms
get up early.  And I have to make a lunch every morning. It's
usually a lot of kyaraben, but I've been crazy for about an hour, so it certainly
takes time, but I'm
teaching people who have a lot of kyaraben.
There are always about 4 to 6 mothers who lay out how to make kyaraben,
but if you want to cut Lee's kyaraben or shape it with a wrap, you should
stop it with mayonnaise.
Depending on the kindergarten, I've only heard it by rumors, but
it seems that having a kyaraben itself is prohibited in some kindergartens.
Don't commit it, don't compete,
or make sure your moms who can't make it don't let kindergartens have something like that.
Of course, I think it's going to be effective, and I'd like to give it to some kind of character,
but of course I want to take care of it, but it's
food, so it's delicious to eat.
For me, I'm most happy to see the smiles of children as much as I can, but when
I make it like this, I can feel the sense of accomplishment myself, so
I'm making it while enjoying that part.
[Music]